this tourist area in port Segura is
called passive allah dhu-l cord or
catwalk of alcohol
and this is tapioca a dish that
originated with Brazil's indigenous
population it's made of starch extracted
from the cassava root it's turn into a
kind of clip and filled with various
fillings both sweet and savory here at
the tapioca king snack bar it's offered
in 48 varieties most of them were
invented by Jose Valdo I present the
customers with a new combination every
day they like them so that's why we have
so many varieties today tapioca is the
name of both the cassava starch and the
finished dish Arianna shows us how to
make a tapioca yes chopped dried meat
if your poo discuss of a puree Tomatoes
it's finished off with butter and
oregano oregano
the tapioca is served folded over
and how do the customers like it
my uncle strawberries with sweetened
condensed milk tastes great I came here
especially to try it the quality is very
good
and by the way the snack bar stays open
until 7 a.m. on certain holidays